many men have won the cows since the
very first batman film hit the big
screen and every batman actor has
brought a different point of view and a
different feeling to the role the tones
have spanned from angstfield drama to
sly suave crime capers and it seems as
if there are hundreds of different ways
to play the cape's crusader just before
twilight star robert pattinson took on
the dark knight for this years to batman
there was ben affleck who was bruce
wayne and his gloomy alter ego in both
batman v superman dawn of justice and
justice league affleck has always been
outspoken about the reason why he took
the role on and the reason why he
departed the batman before it went into
production which allowed for pattinson
to board the project the actor told the
new york times in 2020 i showed somebody
the batman script they said i think the
script is good i also think you'll drink
yourself to death if you go through what
you just went through again but when he
left the role he ended up changing the
project in a completely unexpected way
how did affleck's departure from the
batman end up changing the face of the
film forever february 2022 new york
times article about the batman director
matt reeves the original version of the
film was to feature ben affleck's
version of bruce wayne the film was
slated to take a look at batman through
a different lens that's of an older
wayne more mature instead of a young
trust fund there covering up his
vigilantism with an amassed life as a
devil may care playboy affleck was also
supposed to write and direct the movie
but eventually decided that he would
simply act in the film reeves himself
eventually co-wrote the version of the
batman which he would one day direct
along with co-writer peter craig of bad
boys for life reeves had entered the
picture after multiple directors were
suggested and he said the script he was
presented with was an action set piece
adventure in the time it took for reeves
to complete the final film in his planet
of the apes reboot trilogy 2017's war
for the planet of the apes affleck had
left the project reeves said to the
times i think ben was just evaluating
what he wanted to do and it wasn't what
i think he had fallen in love with in
terms of playing that character in the
first place but his departure definitely
affected the future of the batman as
that meant reeves though had to forge
ahead without his leading man he chose
to do this in a way that would both
honor batman's long past and push him to
new and different heights and reeves and
craig would have to be the ones to take
him there in the wake of ben affleck's
leaving the project matt reeve's goal
was to present a batman who would be
changed completely by the events of the
film reeves told the new york times i
wanted the stakes of the story to
challenge him in a way that shook him to
his core instead of a movie about a
disillusioned wayne forced a face that
his vigilante ways weren't getting the
job done the movie would now center
around quote someone who hadn't quite
figured out why they were doing the
thing they were doing reeves continued
to say that for his version of bruce
wayne he's still stuck in those events
that happened when he was 10. with this
in mind the project zeroed in on a time
period several years into his life as
batman soon enough reeves had his new
batman and robert pattinson a choice
that affleck ultimately approved of
calling pattinson a good actor during an
interview and the rest of the
production's pieces slowly fell into
place it isn't the film that fans would
have seen had affleck still being batman
but it definitely seems to be a worthy
entry
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
batman are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]